as a boy looking out from my father's
castle I thought the Sun could never set
on the North so vast did it seem part of
me still does the north is by far the
largest of the Seven Kingdoms
and can fit the other six inside it not
that the others care gold and dump
that's how the southerners see the north
but without the cold a man can't
appreciate the fire in his half without
the rain a man can't appreciate the roof
over his head
let the south of its Sun flowers and
affectations we northerners have home
mine was once Winterfell the ancient
seat of my father's family house Stark
who have ruled the north since the first
men and were once the kings of winter
growing up lady Catelyn made sure I knew
I wasn't a stark no matter how much
blood I shared with her true born
children but where their name rules over
the north
my name is the north snow our land
stretches from the wall down to the neck
a narrow land that devises from the rest
of Westeros legend has it that the
children of the forest flooded it in
their war against the first men that's
true
every Northman owes them a debt of
gratitude the swamps of the neck are as
good as the wall for keeping our
unwelcome armies and if the swamp stone
to tell you the Kronig men should small
shy people who rarely leave those swamps
and who follow house read the
gatekeepers of the north and among the
most important and loyal bannermen of
House Stark also a bit strange
there Arthur fealty once a child is like
no other Lords ancient and dark they
swear by earth and water by bronze and
iron and by Ice and Fire
warehouse Reed holds the gate to the
North house Manderley holds the port
white Harbor the closest thing to a
southern city we have governed by the
closest thing to a southern family we
have generations ago the madeley's were
driven from the reach starts gave them
their land in return for Failte now
white Harbor is the richest city of the
north the mantle east the richest family
not in gold and silver like their
southern counterparts but in fish grain
trade that's for the other Great
Northern houses the Starks brought them
into the folger in the Age of Heroes I
start wrestled now I'm born for bear
island gave it to the Mormons stark
granted to keep and land to a younger
son Carlin in return for putting down a
rebellion his family then grew up into
the Karstarks Starks fought the
wildlings and their kings beyond the
wall beside the umbers of last hearth
thus earning their fealty Bolton's but
then they were the bane of the north a
few were even ruined to where their
enemies flayed skins as clerks but after
centuries of war they too bent the knee
and so House Stark became the kings in
the north but never forgot that they
weren't the north when Aegon and his
dragons landed on Westeros the kings of
the rock in the reach sent all their men
to die to defend their crowns tauren
stark milk to spare his people the same
fate
he placed Duty above pride just as my
brothers in the Nights Watch had done
for thousands of years at the wall many
think of it as the end of the world but
it's not I've seen how the land
stretches much farther than any man
knows into the land of always winter
where the White Walkers came from during
long night after the first men and the
children the forest beat them back
Brandon the Builder raised the wall and
set up the Nights Watch to guard the
realms of men he gave us our oath how
castles and the gift the lands behind
the wall whose farmers and crops sustain
us
southerners may now mock my black
brothers as thieves rapist and worse and
not without cause with the North
remembers why we are there and if we
fall the south will get a very harsh
very cold reminder